supervised learning that has made a huge
impact across the world and now we are
increasingly turning our attention to
more general problems in general
artificial intelligence that will enable
agents to learn on their own and to act
autonomously in the environment so some
examples include training an agent to
play a complicated board game or
training an agent to drive a car or
training personalized assistants that
can help around the house so in this
talk i'll give a brief overview of some
of the big challenges in achieving these
goals and even more ambitious goals and
some techniques that have been developed
to address them
so what are some algorithmic challenges
in reinforcement learning first it
should work well on data encountered in
the real world and this includes data
with temporal dependencies and when
there's distribution shift between the
training data set and the real world
data and also in general algorithms
should be data and computationally
efficient
and so the problem of reinforcement
learning is the setting where we have an
agent that is interacting with the
environment by taking actions
and earning rewards and then
transitioning to the next state so the
observations are the state action reward
next state about tuples that the agent
gets from the environment
might
cursor is not working
okay okay so the environment is normally
modeled as a markov decision process
where we have states s actions a rewards
are bounded between zero and one and p
of s prime given s a is the transition
probability to state s prime by taking
action a from state s we have a discount
factor gamma between zero and one that
discounts the present value of future
rewards and in reinforcement learning
we're often concerned with policies pi
that are mappings from the states to
actions that tells an agent what action
to take at any given state and we
evaluate better or worse policies using
their value so v pi is the expected
infinite horizon sum of discounted
rewards from starting at state s naught
taking action a and transitioning
according to the dynamics of the
environment
and so the first problem is that
typically in reinforcement learning data
or data sets from the real world there
is a temporal dependence in this data
set and temporally dependent data slows
down learning because subsequent
observations that you see are very close
to each other
and so one way that people have
developed and practice to deal with this
is to use an experience replay to break
temporal dependencies and to speed up
learning so to experience replay works
in the following way we save transition
state action reward next state into a
buffer and then we sample from this
buffer and we use the samples from this
buffer to train the agent so that
subsequent observations that the agent
sees are not going to be as temporarily
dependent they're going to be closer to
an iid case
and so we study experience replay in the
context of least squares regression so
we have our observations y equals to x
transpose w star w star is the learnable
parameter and x is uh markovian data so
our features x come from a markov chain
which is the auto regressive chain which
is a sort of like a random walk
and we want to minimize the out of
population loss of a sample from the
stationary distribution so that's our
loss
and so our main result is that sgd with
experience replay for the auto
aggressive chain can speed up the
learning so we show an upper bound for
sgd with experience replay uh that where
the loss decays exponentially and the
number of time steps over the square
root of the mixing time and we show a
lower round for sequential sgd so
without experience replay where the loss
decays exponentially and in the number
of iterations over the mixing time so we
plot the log loss on the right we see
that uh the loss for sgd with experience
replay is bounded in the green region
and the loss for sequential sgd is in
the red region as a function of the
number of iterations t this is one of
the first analyses for experience replay
oh okay and the second um
so the second uh
main challenge in reinforcement learning
is the issue of distribution shift
between the training data and what the
real world data and this is particularly
relevant in the case of offline
reinforcement learning so in many real
world scenarios the deployment of a
poorly understood policy for the
purposes of online learning can be too
costly or too risky so we must rely only
on the offline data set to find a
reasonable policy for deployment
and so say that we have a fixed data set
of trajectories collected by some
behavioral policy
s not
a r that is not coming from the policy
that you're actually interested in
understanding
so there is a distribution shift between
these two data sets
and we also want to look at the problem
of off policy evaluation which arises in
main two main contexts so the first is a
ranking problem given a set of potential
target policies that you're interested
in for deployment pi one through pi n
evaluate them and pick the best one to
deploy could be the highest value policy
or the safest policy and the second
situation is for offline learning so as
a subroutine for offline learning agents
need to iterate towards better policies
based on accurate value estimates from
off policy
evaluation and so we mainly focus on the
problem of ranking
and one main one very popular algorithm
for of policy evaluation is fitted q
evaluation and
in terms of accuracy recent papers have
shown that it achieves state-of-the-art
accuracy however there is also work out
there that talks about the stability of
fqe in particular it can diverge to plus
or negative infinity for both
linear and non-linear function
approximation
so we wanted to understand how
architecture and representation affects
stability and accuracy for fqe and
variants
so we started off with a very popular
model in deep learning which is the
multi-layer perceptron with layer
normalization for the input layer and
then for fqe
using this architecture for a lot of for
many of the deepmind control suite tasks
we see a lot of instability wild
oscillations and in the last two figures
divergence to plus or minus infinity for
the value estimates and we saw
that architectures that use implicit
regularization can improve stability
without sacrificing the accuracy of the
overall estimate and so we have a few
examples of better architectures on the
bottom for example using a resnet or
using a distributional fqe which is a
different loss it's a distributional
loss
not an l2 loss so this is more in line
with the work on distributional rl and
the third one is a architecture that is
inspired from multitask learning so f2e
with a shared representation and the
last one is fqe with a hyper model which
is basically trying to smooth out an
ensemble it's an ensemble at scale and
so there's implicit regularization there
and uh in the last part of this talk
i'll talk about general data efficient
algorithms
in the presence of a generative model so
in the presence of a generative model a
simulator produces samples of s prime
for any state action pair with
probability p of s prime given s a and
so the algorithm gets to query from the
simulator to learn the optimal policy
and this is useful for certain
applications where simulators exist or
are easily constructed for example video
encoding applications or physics
simulators for robotics
such as the control suite tasks
and our result is a model free mini max
optimal method for finding the epsilon
optimal policy and there are also model
based mini max optimal methods using a
generative model as well and so our main
result is that we can compute an epsilon
optimal policy with high probability
using sample complexity and runtime that
is logarithmic and 1 over delta 1 over
epsilon and this is nearly linear this
is a nearly linear time nearly linearly
convergent algorithms for solving
discounted mdps and we have a second
algorithm that computes an epsilon
optimal policy with high probability and
sample complexity and runtime that is
cubic and one over one minus gamma and
this is nearly optimal up to log factors
and sample and runtime complexity using
only the generative model
and so in conclusion my research or my
goals are to build solutions that are
simple easy to understand explain and
engineer effective that they work well
in practice and also are theoretically
well-rounded thank you
thanks karen
got some questions
maybe tell us a little bit about where
the
logarithmic dependence on epsilon
arrives in the um
uh
the
positive result about
with the generative model
uh yeah it was it's a variance reduced
value iteration method so
i don't i don't know how well the
audience is familiar with value
iteration but it's a successive
approximation method um
basically you uh you you like solve
for it's an iterative method right you
solve you start off with a value vector
and then you
uh you and then you use the bellman
updates uh and then you're getting
closer and closer to the
true uh value function via a fixed point
uh contraction mapping properties of
the bellman operator and so basically
our uh and so
when you use that with a generative
model basically when you have a
generative model you use the simulator
to produce samples of s prime so
basically the algorithm will query from
the simulator to get uh samples of s
prime from the from the uh like
according to the real transition
probabilities and so instead of having
uh like exact value iteration uh uh
exact value iterations you have like
approximate value iterations and then so
our variance reduced
method on top of that it's very simple
and it's inspired by like various
variants reduced sgd that's already out
there basically we like save um
we like save milestone vectors along the
way so that instead of a querying um
instead of querying from the previous um
value vector we're gonna
we're gonna query from like these
milestone query vectors or value vectors
sorry if that makes sense
thanks very much yeah all right thanks
and the last week for this session is